cyberpunk 2077 just keeps on getting
better the game has already received
some substantial upgrades this year and
now patch 1.61 has been announced for PC
console and stadia rest in peace several
fixes from multiple missions will be
added as a number of these gigs had
issues where elements weren't being
properly triggered inside of the game
some quests also saw a progress blocked
by random bugs and you can expect a few
fixes for cyber psycho sightings as well
visually you'll see night City residents
carrying around umbrellas various
floating items will ReDiscover the pull
of gravity and a bug related to missing
collisions won't make you fall through
the map as for gameplay it'll be
possible to craft a legendary variant of
the amnesty iconic revolver clothing
bonuses related to the quick hatch
cooldowns and crit damage will start
working and weapons will be able to deal
more explosive damage for specific fixes
cdpr has fine-tuned Xbox One
cross-platform saves so that they'll
transfer properly to PS4 and PC the dev
has also addressed a PC issue with
temporary frame rate drops when exiting
menus and stadia players can now pause
the game for the few months that the
service is still around for again rest
in peace I'm so sorry I'll leave a link
to the full list of patch notes in the
description below that link I'll also
leave one for God of War ragnarok's day
one patch the game is almost here and it
goes without saying that this is one
patch you'll definitely want to install
before booting up the game as it fixes a
wide variety of bugs crashes and other
technical issues that would otherwise
Mark your experience some of the bug
squashed here are quite amusing
including one that apparently causes the
final boss not to spawn in during the
game's conclusion maybe the words I
meant to use was terrifying and
infuriating but at least it's fixed
because that would be very
anti-climactic the same goes for
multiple loading issues that cause the
player to fall out of the world in
several of the game's key quests other
problems fixed and include missing map
markers incorrect boss health bars blank
lore entries lingering subtitles and
hard crashes during key quests another
game getting a glow up is Halo infinite
the game's winter update drops today
even though it's very much still autumn
in America but this may be the update to
bring me back in because it finally
introduces the new XP system that
rewards you for completing matches and
your performances in game will dictate
how much xp you get the winter update
will also bring Network campaign co-op
the forge beta and two new official
Forge created Maps the first is Argyle
an enclosed map set inside a forerunner
structure the second is Detachment set
in a UNSC base which features halo
infinite's first teleporter if you want
to know about the weapons balancing
coming to the game with this update then
make sure you check the link in the
description it'll be down there close to
all the other links I mentioned in this
video so are you excited to play Halo
again or is over Watch 2 in Modern
Warfare 2 completely taking up all your
time and you can't see a world where you
go back to infinite I'm definitely going
to dip my toe today maybe it will be
able to suck me back in at least until
Modern Warfare 2's first season starts
but we'll see how it goes I'll see you
tomorrow
laughs